[Music]
welcome to the pretzel show I'm aja and
I'm Krista and we are regular moms who
have been pregnant and are here to talk
with you about any and all things
pregnancy in hopes to make your journey
a little bit easier today we have our
special guest Mira who is five months
pregnant with her first baby
hi guys go ahead and have a seat in our
pregnancy throne so how are you feeling
it five months you know I feel like it's
getting better like I'm still waiting
for that burst of energy that everyone's
talking about that has yet to arrive
what are you craving now I want tomato
sandwiches like a hundred percent of the
time describe a tomato sandwich it has
to be like a very cheap Wonder bread a
large amount of mayonnaise a bunch of
slices of tomato and salt and pepper and
then you have to cut it in a triangle or
I'm not gonna eat it we've done a lot of
posts where we talk about crazy cravings
and we have people send in their crazy
cravings which some of them are insane
we want to explore some of those
cravings so let's check them out
[Music]
would you like first dips there's no
like appropriate waiting again with the
front I don't know what that did in my
mouth at did something weird in my mouth
and I don't know if I'll ever taste the
same I just like a pickle it's kind of
weird but not though I'm not the worst
thing I've ever had mm-hmm I think this
could be a solid Ben and Jerry's flavor
Oh handles and hot fudge kind of like
chunky monkey yeah yeah suggest it oh my
god this one's really soaked when do you
think oh it's cold I don't think this is
any worse than the pickle in the
chocolate terrible strawberry fish for
breakfast bull no it's no pickle and
fudge but it's not that okay no very
juicy
I hate meaning so much this is my
favorite oh lordy oh god I should have
smelled it pregnant people like this
it's really good you know hey I'm not a
fan of the mail no I heard that
I think we're we're craving right now I
definitely got like a big whoosh of
mayonnaise like squirting out from
around it's like Oh Mira can't do it
it's the mayo it's like oozing out of my
mouth and also coming out the other end
I don't even wanna think about oh so we
just came from our taste test and we are
ready for a delicious cocktail this is a
mocktail recipe a faux hito that we got
from our good friends at tasty and we're
gonna check it out
[Music]
emerging we know a lot of pregnant women
go by the one glass of red wine a week
rule is that something that's okay is
that really safe for the baby the answer
is don't know okay let me tell you what
we do know about alcohol in pregnancy
that's probably a good place to start we
do know that women who drink two or more
glasses of alcohol a day are putting
their babies at risk that we have very
good data on or we can show bad outcomes
there the problem is that nobody has
exact data on what's the absolute lowest
limit that women can handle we just
don't know this you know my standard
line that I say to my patients is if
you're going to your cousin's wedding
and you're pregnant and you want to
toast the bride I think a glass of
champagne to toast the bride is fine but
I don't want you drinking the rest of
the bottle so you know on a special
occasion I think it's quite reasonable
and what about Katherine is another very
important area that women are concerned
about that basically the feeling is that
you can do one 12-ounce cup of coffee a
day the limit is about 200 milligrams of
caffeine as sort of what's felt to be
contained in one of these twelve ounce
cups of coffee and that that's probably
safe there are some papers out there
that will say even that's too high there
are some people that will say you can go
higher but that's sort of a reasonable
ballpark to use well this is all such
great information Mary Jane thank you so
much for your time we'll talk to you
soon thank you thank you
[Music]
we've been around for over 30 years and
we think it was about 1987 when a
past-due mother ate the salad and
started having contractions at the table
and giggle and said oh the salad is
putting me into labor
and she actually went to the hospital
she'd deliver that day she told her
friends they told their friends and just
word of mouth just it has its own legs
it's just been an organic thing and
there's no other way to describe it it's
just kind of a phenomenon
[Music]
so tell us a little bit about I told you
she does like I don't think we're gonna
be any and I'm like oh no we're going to
Italy this belt is on show labor right
yes
how many pregnant women would you say
come in in a week in a week let's do it
day because yes in a day we probably
have a slow day as maybe 10 and average
day is maybe 20 and a busy day is thirty
pregnant ladies a day that doesn't count
the two goes because you can always tell
when it's to go order when a man comes
in and he looks really tired
it sounds like science behind it to kind
of like they're my doctor implied that
there couldn't be science behind it but
he did not say anything fitted
[Music]
[Applause]
over here president what do you think
they're in the water
it's bananas
that's a wrap for today thanks so much
for joining us we had so much fun
discussing all things pregnancy with you
and thanks so much Mira for being here
we look forward to being updated about
babies Sonny and we hope everything goes
smoothly for the rest of your pregnancy
thanks guys I'll definitely keep in
touch I really appreciate all those hips
it was really fun yeah should we grab a
selfie yeah
[Music]
you